well let's talk about let's let's let's
now jump into the uh the financial
aspect of all of this
the uh as i mentioned you know joe
biden's printing six trillion dollars
now he's got a new proposal
more money pumped into the system it's
gonna hire people to build stuff but uh
the wall street journal reported that
people
had a decent amount of savings people
have people are flush with cash they
said families have cash there's just no
supply there's
there's demand no supply so if people
can't buy what they want to buy
and there's nothing that's going to
bring it back why would they go start
working again
if joe biden prints all this money and
says we're gonna hire you to go build a
bridge they're gonna be like for what
i got a bunch of money and i can't buy
the ps5 anyway
so now we're seeing something
interesting people with a bunch of money
and nothing to do with it and this is
where we get to this story from market
watch
a huge day for meme stocks sees mudric
reportedly dump amc stock and roaring
kitty returns to
rally gamestop die hards what does this
mean
yeah okay so uh roaring kitty
and i'm sure a lot of people might know
the the details a lot of this stuff
um but so i'll just i'll just briefly
mention there's meme stocks
there's you know gamestop amc i think
what kodak nokia were those
part of the bush so uh people started
buying this stuff
because memes were popping up telling
people to buy it but there was
sound motivation behind it i guess it
started with with gamestop
so i covered this a little bit we talked
about on the show as the game stop
rebellion
people were basically saying these hedge
funds are committing illegal act
are engaging in illegal activities
they're doing naked short selling
they're shorting more
more shares that actually exist which is
manipulating and destroying these
companies which is
unfair and so this dude's like i like
the stock and he buys a bunch of it
rallies a bunch of people and i i
wouldn't say directly he's like hey look
what i'm doing
so then people were like we'll buy the
stock too and it's screwed over all
these hedge funds
so a lot of this ties into crypto but
let's just start from the beginning
and then you know take us to where where
we got to go
what's happening right now amc is up
38.50 i think it's like a share of amc
so there it was at one point like a
couple bucks
people are shorting it so what's going
on tell us what's happening yeah well
first of all congratulations i know
there was a lot of people were watching
it today
after hours it's just continuing to go
bonkers and really this entire
group of socks were just highly shorted
ones and it all started with this
roaring kitty character back in 2019
he just slowly but surely on reddit
posted he liked it
gamestop and throughout 2020 it really
got some traction just
the stock was doing a bit better but
people like the size of it like
way back in 2019 he put like fifty
thousand dollars on it or yeah fifty
thousand and
confident and then in 2020 the world
shut down
a lot more internet consumption people
started taking note of it and then
in january it started to pick up and
that's when it went crazy like
he was up millions of dollars that's
just like one guy
it was just insane and like everyone's
looking out of money and he just it was
funny because like
he was the guy who started all of this
he was diamond handing it no matter what
i think a lot of people faced with that
money were like oh how could you not
take it and he just
kept he didn't give up so explain
diamond hands
we have a shirt but you can yeah diamond
hands it's more of a reference to
oh really almost poker like if you have
a strong hand you don't fold so diamond
being the strongest thing it's like
you're just not fully no matter what
happens technically fundamentally
you are just not getting out of the
position and
that just caught i think it was really
the perfect storm
of a couple psychological events of
people in 2020 hurting for money
sitting around hearing this cool story
it was perfect it played into that
narrative that resonates with a lot of
people
of david and goliath it was this
underdog this one guy calling himself
roaring kitty
and well he actually uh has uh the other
name dfv
and people just liked it they liked that
value yeah they liked where it was going
with it
and then when it it exploded in january
for those of you who don't like haven't
been following the story that closely
in late january before we knew it
gamestop was trading sub 50 and at one
point in pre-market was about 500 and
market hours was about 400 it was just
it was going so crazy
and people were making a lot a lot of
money so at that point
what had happened is this all happened
because there was a high short interest
in the world of stocks you buy a stock
you hope it goes from x up to y and you
profit that difference
you said i was like if it goes if you
buy a stock at five it goes to ten
sell it you get five bucks profit yep
exactly so in the stock market there is
an option to do the opposite
you can sell it at y hope it goes down
from ten down to three and you profit
seven
so with that the only way to pull that
off is how could you sell something you
don't own
well you end up borrowing it from
someone and it's basically an iou you
want it to go down you buy it back
and you give it to that person well it
got so out of hand
with gamestop at one point out of all
the shares in existence there was a
hundred and forty percent short interest
against it so like people are like how
is that possible
how could you possibly short more of the
stock than even exists
because like someone was borrowing it
and then selling it to someone else who
was then used
using it to like and then someone
borrowed it from him yeah it was just
this never-ending daisy chain of i own
it
i loan it to you you short it he buys it
he loans it out it was just
buying loaning shorting buying loaning
shorting and it was just recycling and
it got so huge
and actually what we just explained to
the letter of the law right now not a
financial advisor not a lawyer
but that's legal that is a legal
practice right there you can do that
naked short selling
that's what i just described is not
naked short selling
so that's normal shorting and that's
allowed and what it is it's just the
amount of people
are getting caught because like when you
have that much money betting against a
stock
historically it does go down because
it's just big money they must know
something we must be getting it right
but once in a blue moon there's enough
people that
start to pile in against that trade and
to get out of short
to close that position you have to buy
back to the market
well say i have a big short i closed
mine i lost a little bit
but because i bought it to close a
position at a small loss it goes up a
little higher
well you hit your risk tolerance you're
another short it goes up a little higher
you hit your risk tolerance and before
you know it it gets so
wildly out of hand because all the
shorts are covering they've gotta buy
stock to cover yeah they hit their risk
tolerance and like
if you own a stock your risk is
technically capped if it goes to zero
if you're short of stock your risk is
technically infinite because it could
just keep going up and up and up
and that's what happened when you have
so many shorts mathematically the
ceiling just goes higher and higher for
every short
and so people saw this phenomena and
they found other
highly shorted stocks so gamestop led
and like hey i kind of missed that train
but all of a sudden you have bb
no cost and one that really really
caught people's attention and honestly
why i'm here right now
is because of amc so people noticed it
and in early february all these highly
shorted socks kind of took a breather
but at that point the amc community
specifically
it exploded on reddit twitter and
youtube why
i think something about the point of it
was a psychology play of with gamestop
if it was trading at 200 bucks
you could buy one share and then if amc
is trading at 10 you could buy 20.
so you just felt like you could buy more
like there was more of a psychological
reward
especially with a potential massive
squeeze incoming it's like well make
more money people just wanted more
shares
what's kind of funny about that is that
it doesn't matter how many you have it
matters the percentage gained
yeah you know so if you if you like when
it comes to bitcoin everyone's like oh i
can't spend 40 grand in a bitcoin it's
like no it's a percentage gain
it's like you put in 100 bucks and it
goes up 10 you made 10 bucks it doesn't
doesn't matter however
when you realize that people think that
way then it actually kind of is better
to have stocks that are cheaper
because instead of thinking about
percentage the person buying is going to
be like
wow it's only a dollar i can buy 10. so
they actually drive the price up faster
because the stock is worth less per sh
or it's worth less per share yeah
and with that as the community grew
this is like they were talking about
naked shorted with the first game
something but now that it's been a
couple months since early february
there's been so much dd and research
going on and this is where we entered
naked shorts which isn't a legal
practice so
in the example of i own shares i loan it
out to you you borrow it you pay the fee
you short and that daisy chains
so what naked shorting is is actually
when you take the short position
and you never ever borrowed it it just
did not exist so
you just added more supply out of
nowhere it exists digitally but you're
in
increasing supply demand stays the same
so it's driving the stock down
you just increase supply like so with
that and then it gets more out of hand
because you bought these fake shorted
chairs like people refer to them as
synthetic shares because they never
should have been shorted
you bought them off of him you think you
have legitimate shares so then you loan
them out to someone who actually want a
short
and you get this tree root system of all
these actions that should have never
happened because the initial naked short
so the system is basically it's got a
bunch of hollow points
and then what when when the when when it
comes due what happens
so that's the interesting thing is so
the way
we're using a broker you like you sign
up to weeble or whatever it is you have
a broker well hedge funds have prime
brokers
and just a fancy name for whoever
facilitates their trades
so really the prime broker is the person
who is supposed to locate the shares for
them to short
but to the best of my understanding they
have like two days to locate them
sometimes they don't and they can even
kick that can down the road and before
you know it in high volatility stocks
through so many trades so much
and you just don't know how out of hand
it gets so really they get a slap on the
wrist they're supposed to buy the shares
that
should have never existed off the market
and they did it
but one of the main things i kind of
stress to my audience is
yeah okay you bought those shares off
but there's no way to
get back any of the damage that was done
from like the result of how long they
were on the market so so hold let's
think about a second
uh it sounds to me like uh what what's
what's what's amc
amc uh currently short interest what
percentage of amc is 18
and that's the ones that are legitimate
legal shorts
inherently you can no there's no way to
track illegitimate shorts because they
were never documented and hence why
they're illegitimate was it wasn't
gamestop like over 100
it was at 140 at its peak where's it at
now
20 percent 20 minutes so it's way way
down in terms of yeah but but if it's
over 100
then it's basically like a guarantee
they're gonna have to buy your shares
off you at some point no matter what the
price is
not a guarantee because with that much
money betting against it usually they're
right and they actually drive it down
that was the argument is that there were
so many hedge funds piling
against amc gme and these others like
there was a good chance of them
forcing it to go bankrupt but with a
whole bunch of bored
internet people yeah that's a really
difficult thing to go up against
it's a hive of bored people with
stimulus checks you know
and i think that's one of the things
really going against the hedge funds
right now
of from early february till now the
community specifically
in amc is getting bigger and bigger and
bigger uh the ceo adam aaron was talking
about
there's 3.2 million retail investors
individual investors and that was
actually a little bit ago
so now it's just the word is spreading
even this me talking here
more people are finding out about it and
it's getting bigger and bigger and
bigger so
at first it was the story line of david
and goliath the little retail traders
but now there's so many little davids
that you almost have like a whole nother
goliath
versus that original gloss this is
interesting there's there's some
questions about
the the the security and the value of
like a stock for instance because they
can always dilute you know when we look
at dogecoin for instance the price goes
up simply because
it is a scarce commodity to a certain
degree its price reflects its scarcity
and the demand for it so bitcoin
is becoming increasingly more scarce
just by nature of what bitcoin is
people want to use it because it's a
safe decentralized store of value
so the more people want to use it the
price just keeps going up so people are
holding it are happy and people want to
get in because it's going up and it's
like a system where everyone's just like
we got to buy more which just drives the
price higher and higher
with stocks they could dilute and that
could negatively impact you all of a
sudden there's more shares they get sold
and now
it devalues a lot of you know a lot of
these shares but at the same time
it's not incredibly common that they'll
just keep printing shares right it's not
they can't just do that can they
well there is a process where you like
ask for shareholder approval to
authorize new shares then they're
authorized and
the board and the leadership team when
they deem it necessary then they
can do it so like there is a certain i
guess process that they're going to go
through but even talking about that that
happened to amc today
so well the price still went way up
exactly so it's not a definitive thing
because sometimes
you're diluting or you're you're doing
an at the market offering to raise money
and then it's the perception of the
public of did they do it for a
legitimate good reason
so yesterday they sold about 8.5 million
shares for around 27
they raised 230 million the reasoning
for it and the ceo tweeted out was to
acquire more movie theaters expand their
market share
and then today well this is a whole
nother weird uh i guess turn of events
it gapped up it was strong
midday the hedge fund that bought it
actually
sold it and they not only sold it they
did it all at once
and they did it during the market hour
which is a really really sneaky tactic
and the reason it's sneaky is because
midday especially from 12 to 1
everyone's on lunch it's the lowest
volume part of the day
wow so whatever you do has the biggest
impact
so the whole point of that
psychologically is you see the jump
people get scared they get an alert and
it trus it causes like
actual capitulation people are like
what's happening yeah it hit it stop
loss orders it cause capitulation
and then people get scared like hang on
i don't know what's going on it
people the one of the quickest things to
drive a market
up or down is greed and fear and that's
what you do like
so when stock goes up you have fomo buy
they just see it ripping and everyone's
like i want to buy you hop in on it
the opposite true is you see a big red
bar you get scared and
because you get scared you sell someone
else to sell like
the stock market is so emotionally
driven
and sometimes that could be used to a
benefit and other times it's not
but it was just so strange that they
bought it at 27
like that and then they sold it today
and
not only was it a weird timing and they
did it all at once you could see the
volume traded in like a particular three
minute time
frame but beyond that they went out of
their way to make a public
statement that it's overvalued so within
one day they loved it at 27 and then
they tried to drop it at
33 they're scamming the market yeah
that's what it sounds like and it's
weird because like
you'll have some correspondence talking
about all these retail traders
manipulating the market
how is that not right when you know
people are paying attention to it and
you go out of your way to make a public
statement
where it's just listened to and that's
what why this
is getting they're just throwing
gasoline onto the fire with this type of
thing when you act that way
because people who are on the fence of
like maybe there isn't manipulation
maybe we're overstating it then they
hear story lines like this and you're
like
what are you possibly doing like it's so
so bad and then
there's a couple of things more things
that play into it but then the reader
media reports on it and it's always like
retail they shouldn't be doing this blah
blah blah like it just gets so out of
hand and it's just
feeding the fire bigger and bigger this
is what i was saying earlier on with the
other segment about you know meat
shortages and stuff was
uh that it's like the system is is
collapsing and they're trying to stop
they're trying to bail water but they're
making it worse i look at this way
they they they issue this unemployment
bonus you know everybody's now getting
extra 300 bucks a lot of people have
money from
you know their jobs not everybody was
working but people have money from
unemployment and nothing to buy
so here's something you could buy you
can download an app and just buy
something it's like what else you gonna
do with it right
so all of a sudden now you've got this
massive short interest on stocks like
gamestop or amc or whatever else
and 3.2 million retail investors who
can't go anywhere can't do anything on
our board and are like yeah i'll join in
i'll buy something
so you've got this this this lockdown
they shut everything down it damages the
economy
then at the same time people have
nothing to do so they switch to this
which causes hype
this it's it's like everybody pointing a
laser pointer at the same spot at the
same time with like
millions of people it's gonna actually
you know start burning
and now the hedge funds are freaking out
so it's like
you know biden and the democrats think
we're gonna do this unemployment bonus
it's going to help people but instead it
just causes more destabilization in a
sense
if if people are able to or i i i don't
want to frame like a bad thing
i mean these hedge funds shouldn't be
able shouldn't be able to do what they
do anyway
you know we had uh are you familiar with
max keiser no so max keiser is a big
financial guy he's a big bitcoin guy
and he was on the show talking about how
these hedge funds get they get free
money from the government anyway
the government just prints stuff gives
out the loans from the fed and then they
can just do whatever they want with it
and it manipulates the whole system and
it basically strips the value from
working-class people
all of a sudden whether intentional or
not working-class people said
i want to play the game too and now
they're you know firing their lasers all
in the same direction and it's causing
serious problems for the ultra elites
and the financial system itself which
has been stripping value from
working-class people
it's just it's exactly that it's that
like the pompous attitude of
an elitist of like i know what's best
i'm doing it right
let me gut the economy to make millions
or billions myself
and like working class hey you'll be
fine like just i'm right i know what's
going on with money
and they get so so angry about it of
like they're using all these antiquated
models of like fundamental analysis of
game stops overvalued amc we have to
short it you don't know what you're
talking about well
at the end of the day value is a
perceived concept
if i want to buy amc at 50 and if enough
people want to buy that 50
it's gonna trade at 50. that's all it is
there's no rules it's
it's unsettling to some people but it is
legitimately a house of cards and we
we're the ones who give it value enough
people give it value
and that's what it's going to trade at
so is 18
short interest enough to actually have
like a massive
short like gamestop yeah so that that's
an awesome question
uh obviously people compared to gamestop
and they're like hang on that's a lot
lower
um in terms of magnitude it is
considerable uh tesla is considered to
be a highly shorted stock it's not at
six percent and then you have a
normal stock so tesla's at like five
something five point eight percent sure
that's considered high
yeah that that's a shorted stock and
then a normal stock like apple's at
point eight percent
shorting is a very abnormal tactic in
the stock market
most funds most everything is a long
only you're buying and you're hoping it
goes up
um shorting is definitely bucking the
trend so i get it
18 20 uh what gamestop is that now is
just like i think it's 20.6 the last
time i checked
um yeah it's still just high the
magnitude is there
because as of now in existence there's
about 500 million shares of amc that's
how many there are so that means there's
about 135 million
roughly that are on loan that we know
about that could be legitimate shorts so
what happens is it goes up
those hundred thirty-ish million shares
have to be covered for
at a certain point they're going to hit
their risk the
price has to keep going up yeah and
beyond that
their back is like they're fighting time
because
every single day they pay a borrow fee
but if you own amc
you just sit there so so pay no extra
fee you're just like
let's see how this goes thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time